you had meant said a couple of things
about you know women in college and all
that's part of the problem nowadays with
College college is not learning anymore
it's just partying nothing wrong with it
you go you binge drink you become an
alcoholic and and I think men if you're
going to look for someone who I don't
want to say virtuous or has those values
I probably wouldn't go to a bar I
probably wouldn't be on Tinder I mean
that's just maybe one of my suggestions
yeah uh I I if you want to comment to
that well hold on I want to keep it
right there for a second guys because
yeah I think the interesting thing you
were touching on before is there's a
certain thing that women respond to as a
guy
a lot of times I joked you know hey
we're not that far off from the caveman
we're dragging our Knuckles kind of [ __ ]
right and so we're looking for
conversion at some point in our lives
like converting a female to a companion
and I think that's the big Gap is like
we don't know how to do it so people
turn to alcohol and these other things
in the in the easy bars and things like
that so so I think the challenges is
like we don't know as like idiot knuckle
drag or cavemen how to connect with the
opposite sex and I think you're alluding
to that uh before Rich so maybe you can
touch on that a little bit and then find
where that intersection is uh to Geno's
later point because I think there's
something that comes before that and
it's that connection piece
um okay so what do you want to deal with
specifically in that statement because
there's a few things that we took you
know I think I think I think you know in
the way my mind works is that young men
struggle to make a connection with women
we're awkward we have a [ __ ] ton of
testosterone we don't really know how to
do it so there's there's like how do we
make that connection well the bar is an
easy layup it sounds like Gino's arguing
for a higher level self to make a
connection and maybe like find another
uh a place to meet and entertain women
so I think it's just maybe and you're it
sounded like if I'm not mistaken you're
referring to a way to get women to
respond to you so maybe starting there
and then finding better places to you
know find you know someone that that may
be a better fit for you if you if you do
have virtue Jake before Rich answers
that the question now listen listen oh
listen the problem
it was like a five minute question you
just get it out of the time out the
problem is Right nowadays is there are
no strong fathers right now I've got
five daughters yes my daughters know how
I treat them I have a 23 year old who
just started dating and she's probably
gonna marry the guy because she knows
how I treat her she knows that I'll take
a bullet oh I didn't hear about this yet
anyway I will do anything for her and
Uncle Jake might have to step in here a
little bit right dude all my other
daughters understand that my son knows
how I treat my wife and how I love my
wife and respect my wife so it all
starts with the nuclear family
Traditional Values I'm sorry and that's
what's going off the rails and we've
we've started with this divorce thing
down the road and now it's okay and now
women got the short end of the stick
because now can they rely on a man or a
husband my wife can rely on stream
ownership that's a problem so I mean
that's where it all starts it starts
with the family and with the head and if
you're a strong man and your daughter
knows what you are and you're not an
[ __ ] you're not going to walk out on
her and she can rely on you then she'll
look for that mate but there aren't that
many guys out there that will stick
around for the next 20 to 25 years
they're they're pissed out after a
couple of years so we're going to give
our guests the floor here and see where
he wants to go with this bag of [ __ ] I
don't know you guys ready to put on some
seat belts and Buckle in for some cold
hard truth bombs let it let Make It Rain
Man there's a lot to talk about that so
to Gino's point with you know fathers
um that appears to be one of the major
problems
um you know on Father's Day it's not
that uncommon if you're on social media
to see the single mommies use Father's
Day as an opportunity to say I do the
job of both parents so I'm awesome
praise me as well and why wouldn't they
Society has been telling you know single
mothers for for decades now you're
strong you're independent you don't need
no man until they need child support or
until they need government handouts or
until whatever right so they still have
the opportunity to raise children but
without the authority of a man in a
household and and the problem with that
is that single mommy households tend to
be absolute beta factories they don't
churn out strong virtuous men and they
generally churn out promiscuous [ __ ]
women
um
so here's some stats from single-parent
households which are more specifically
single mother households because 80
percent of the time women are raising
the kids when it comes to single parent
household probably even a little bit
more maybe even close to about 85
percent of the time
um the vast majority of the incarcerated
single parent household the vast
majority of uh gang activity single
parent household vast majority of
teenage pregnancies vast majority of
dropouts vast majority of suicide
attempts you can go right down the list
uh two parent households with a man and
a woman produce far better members and
far more useful members of society than
ones that are walking around virtuously
pounding their chest saying I am awesome
here's my Offspring the truth of matter
is the vast majority of the guys that
watch my content come from single parent
households they haven't got it right and
they've been conditioned to be kind
humble nice
um these bombs generally turn out weak
pussified men that try to enter the
friend zone to get with the gals and
women don't want weak pussified men they
want strong long virtuous guys that's
what they're attracted to that's what
they've always been attracted to if you
want to distill what works on the sexual
Marketplace as far as attraction between
men and women men compete women choose
you want to boil it down to four you
know a couple words men compete women's
shoes women choose like you know I said
I've said this line many many times and
it Ruffles some feathers I've always
said you know women women don't care
about a man's struggle they wait at the
finish line and they bang the winners
okay women aren't King makers they are
walking around today the vast majority
of them even if they're out of shade out
of shape obnoxious ignorant covered in
tattoos have short purple hair aren't
attractive physically they still walk
around thinking that they are queens and
they're not King makers they're looking
for a guy that's already a winner so
there's a lack of supply of strong
virtuous men there's a lack of supply of
uh feminine beautiful women that strong
virtuous men want to date so the vast
majority of the guys out there are
dating a lot of women simultaneously
like it's it's not uncommon for
successful masculine guys that
understand these facts to be dating
multiple women simultaneously so women
are actually being shared by these are
they aware of that
I think they just generally look the
other way for the most part
right
um you know it's been said that a woman
would rather share a high value alpha
male than be straddled with a faithful
loser it's one of the reasons why
um you know you see a lot of women today
that will be happier dating a successful
married man rather than dating a single
guy that lives in their mom's basement
right because there's a lot of social
proof because that guy's already been
chosen so you know when you get into the
Dynamics of the way things actually work
versus what we've been told and the
direction that Society is sort of going
it's it starts to get very very complex
like men are suffering today the vast
majority of men are lonely single poor
they lack intimacy they're they're
mostly invisible to women I think there
was a statue back to what I was saying
about the the feminist stuff though it's
like yes there's the one percent but the
majority of guys to your point this is
not some some [ __ ] party that that
most guys are on right now no this is
serious man like yeah you know this is a
serious problem today yeah
wow so so what do we do
what there's always that hey how do we
fix this problem Rich so what's this but
let's be honest though like so you know
as a guy take it as my responsibility
fix fix things right it's it's how do we
make the world a better place and I
think that's that's probably lacking
right now yeah so I think that we're
we're we're pretty far down the rabbit
hole when it comes to trying to fix this
like what happened quick though
I'm born in the 80s right like this
seems like a much different world in the
world I was brought up in yeah it's not
a long period of time yeah this type of
[ __ ] I'm guessing I'm guessing Gino's
close to my age as well yeah
born in the 40s you know he looks good
man he looks good for the 40s you know
yeah for you
um no but I was gonna say like like you
know it's it's it's essentially happened
since the sexual Revolution since
hormonal birth control you know happened
baby boomers ruined [ __ ] everything
yeah those Boomers right [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um yeah so it's so it's been a long slow
process of sort of boiling the Frog and
accepting you know mediocrity and you
know weakening and pussifying man
there's a lot of events that you can
take a look at I mean
um I remember when I was a kid you know
I'm a big car guy obviously you know the
name of my main YouTube channel is
entrepreneurs and cars and you know when
I was a kid like there was masculine
cars there was cars that laid rubber
made all kinds of noise burned tons of
fuel they look like men's cars somebody
sent this you know sent me this meme the
other day for my community and it was
every single manufacturer's mid-sized
compact SUV painted in white uh all one
after the another everything from
Mercedes all the way down to Kia and
they all look identical they're boring
ass beige boxes okay fortunately station
wagon fortunately we can still buy our
exotic cars I've got a McLaren I'm very
happy with that you know I'm glad that
you know these car manufacturers still
exist but you know we've gone from a
distinguished sort of society with uh
distinguished roles where men have like
you know Blue Jobs and women sort of
have pink jobs and that was okay but for
some reason you know Society has now
sold this bill a lie well where that's
not okay now and you know it's okay for
men to stay home do you guys remember
the movie Mr Mom back in the 80s Yes
sounds like a an example I don't know
you know an example of like one of the
things that sort of shifted and pivoted
um all of the sitcoms show shows that I
watched when I was growing up the father
was always portrayed as a bumbling idiot
by Hollywood right they were never
portrayed as a strong virtuous male that
you know the wife respected that you
know the children sort of obeyed uh you
know you go back to the shows that we
watch uh you know black and white from
the 40s and 50s and stuff or leave it
you know like to Leave it to Beaver air
sort of thing and some people criticize
oh that's that's all that's all a farce
that's all the patriarchy trying to
control you blah blah blah sort of thing
they've pushed well past that now and
they've pushed into an era now where
Society you know the Matrix as you may
want to call it no but like you could go
down a complete conspiracy theory here
and say this is a collectivist you know
uh type coup here look we don't know
who's at the controls right I mean Joe
Biden certainly isn't at the controls
like the motors it would lead you to
believe that if you want to control
people there's a collectivist type
scheme behind the scenes all I'm saying
like we don't get super conspiracy
theory but aren't soft pussified men
easier to control than so that's the
exact point that I'm making that's the
exact point that I'm making and if you
so how do you get it together stand on
your dots take this experimental
injection and wear a face diaper because
I Told You So and the vast majority of
the North American population comply or
get the [ __ ] out of society exactly
exactly so they've been conditioning us
to become softer more agreeable because
you're easier to control a society that
is in that position is going to vote for
bigger government more taxes less
freedoms people don't want freedom
anymore they want free [ __ ] like watch
the way that they vote